حذرت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه من صعوبه
الوضع في مدينه خرسون في ضوء القصف
المدفعيه الروسي المتواصل وقالت الوزاره
في بيانها اليومي ان خرسون معرضه لخطر
باله لانها ما تزال في نطاق معظم انظمه
المدفعيه الروسيه المتميزه في الضفه
الشرقيه لنهر
واضافت الدفاع البريطانيه انا روسيا
تستخدم قاذفات الصواريخ متعدده الاطلاق
وتسبب ضرارا كبيرا في خرسه
في غضون ذلك قالت اوكرانيا ان روسيا تستعد
لشني موجه جديده من الهجمات الصاروخيه على
شبكه الطاقه الخاصه بها والتي اغرقت
مساحات شاسعه من البلاد في البرد والظلام
وكشف متحدثا عسكريا اوكرانيا لان سفينه
حربيه روسيه قادره على اطلاق صواريخ
الكروس تمركز في البحر الاسود وعلمتني
صواريخ من نوع كلبه وحضر رئيس الاوكراني
في خطاب له من ان روسيا تستعد لهجمات جويه
جديده
قبل ذلك نفت الرئاسه الروسيه قريبه
اوكرانيه حول فقدان السيطره على اداره
محطه زفرونوجيا النوويه جاء ذلك بعد ان
اكد رئيس شركه الطاقه النوويه الاوكرانيه
اكد وجود مؤشرات على ان القوات الروسيه
ربما تستعد
لاخلاء المحطه
العربيه رائد الاخبار رائد اهلا وسهلا بك
جديد المشهد الميداني من عندك اين يتركز
القصف واين تتركز قبل ان اسالك عن
المواضيع الحياتيه من كهرباء وتدفئه
يعني بالفعل طالب هناك جدل كبير بالدرجه
الاولى حول التطورات في مقاطعه زبروجه حيث
اتباين بين تصريحات الروسيه والتصريحات
الاوكرانيه ال- الجانب الاوكراني يقول بان
القوات الروسيه تنسحب من مقاطعه زبروجي
على غرار ما حدث في خلصون بينما تشير
الدفاع الروسيه الا ان ااه هناك اقتحامات
اوكرانيه من قبل منطقه انطلاقا من منطقه
اقرب للمنشئه النوويه
الروسيه يعني تصدها هذه الهجمات وتكبر
بجانب الاوكراني خسائر كبيره وانها دمرت
من الصلاه لصواريخ ودمر مستودعات الاخيره
هناك كذلك هي يعني الدفاعات الجويه تتعرض
الصواريخ المطلقه من الجانب الاخرى ايضا
هي الى ان المناطق التي يسيطر عليها الجيش
الروسي ماذا يسيطر عليها حتى الان منذ
انطلاق العمليه العسكريه في مقاطعه زبرجر
هذا من جانب وجانب الاخر
همم الكريمنا من الروسي على لساند
متريبيسكو المتحدث باسم الرئاسه قال بان
كل ما تعلنه الوكالات او اجانب الاوكراني
غير صحيح وبعيد او عالم من الصحه ال محور
الاخر وهو محور الشرق الاوكراني هنا
بالفعل منذ الامس حتى اليوم هنا قصف مستمر
من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه عمليات ايضا
مداهمه على المثلث ما بين مقاطعه دانيه
تقول الدفاع الروسيه بانها تصدق الى جماعه
وتقتل الجنود اوكرانيين وانها ايضا قادر
على كل الهجمات وتسيطر على المنطقه لكن
التقدم الروسي الوحيد محصور في مقاطعه
الثانيه
اليوم سيطره الطلاب على اربعه بلدات اخرى
والمعارك المحترمه في وسط المدينه حسب
الانباء التي وردتنا من وقت ليس بعيد كما
ان القوات المواليه لروسيا ايضا دخلت
مناطق جديده في مدينه المتاخمه لمدينه
والحديث عن اكمال السيطره على مدينه
رقت بالنسبه الى المواضيع الحياتيه همم
يعني الكلام دائما يطول عن موضوع انه
دوناتك همم يعني لا يوجد فيها مياه للشرب
او مياه للشفع وانه همم هنالك نقص في
الامدادات بالتيار الكهربائي لان هذا دقيق
باختصار
يعني باختصار يعني اتحدث عن تجربتي
الشخصيه يعني انا نفسي اعاني من نقص
المياه تاتي المياه همم ساعتين كل ثلاثه
ايام نسعى نخرج للبحث عن المياه وهمم يعني
نستحم قليلا نستحم بمياه غير نظيفه همم لا
اتحدث عن ناس اتحدث عن نفسي لانني اعيش
مبدئيا في هذه التغطيه في هذه المنطقه
بالفعل لا يوجد مياه لا توجد مياه اصلا
صالحه للشرب
والجانب الاوكراني يقطع المياه من منطقه
اسلاميه حيث نهر السيرفر
ومحطات التنقيه همم مناطق سيطره القوه
الاوكرانيه الكهرباء موجوده الغاز موجود
موجود كل شيء موجود في المنطقه
شكرا جزيلا لك رائد على كل هذه المتابعه